[Music]
joining me today is the creator of the
Dilbert comic strip author of the new
book win big Li and a guy who seems to
make some pretty spot-on predictions
Scott Adams welcome back to the Reuben
report thanks for having me before we
begin I got to tell you I was looking at
these blurbs on the back of this book
how did you get these people William
Shakespeare
Mark Twain Alexander the Great Abe
Lincoln and even the Scott Adams guy I
mean how in the world did you pull this
off I stick with dead people because
they can't complain later it's like not
one of them has complained that I've Mis
quoted him you know Mark Twain he said
nothing about this quote so what I saw
this I thought immediately there must be
in a state for some of these people that
monitor these types of things do you
even have to think about that does the
editor or the publisher go Scott you
can't Wayne come on well luckily my job
is parody yeah and so so I know those
laws pretty well okay as long as it's
obvious parody you can do anything you
want yeah so we checked right before he
walked in we had you on the show
September 1st of 2016 about two months
before the election and when I had you
on you were one of the only people that
I thought basically was making sense of
what was going on with Trump at the time
you you didn't say you were a trump
supporter I think you actually said you
were not a trump supporter you had sort
of said the thing about you were you
know in a hostage situation with Hillary
but you know basically you were saying
here's what Trump is doing I I don't
necessarily support it I think you by
the election time you officially did
support him right
yeah the because of one issue basically
when when Clinton came out with the the
estate tax plan and I realized that I
personally would pay roughly 75 cents on
every dollar I would earn for the rest
of my life which would basically make me
retire yeah I wouldn't possibly work for
that so that that changed my mind yeah I
wasn't gonna jump into the estate tax
but I do find it one of the interesting
things I don't stand to make a windfall
from the estate tax but I find it one of
those things where it's like this money
has been taxed for someone's entire life
your money that you earn through all
your hard work has been taxed your whole
life hopefully you've made good
investments
whatever else you've done I met at the
end the government just says okay we're
gonna just basically take more than half
of it at that point after we've already
taken it the whole time the whole tax
thing there's no way to make it fair
because there's always somebody is gonna
complain but some things just feel less
fair and that feels more like
confiscation than tax yeah but I guess
it's easy to be one of those people that
just are like well I'm not involved in
this I don't stand to win anything of it
so why wouldn't I want to take the money
from other people right yeah yeah that's
the big problem with a democratic system
people can vote vote other people's
money into their pocket if there are
enough of a motive yeah all right so
it's a little over a year ago that we
had you on you're making some sense of
the techniques that are that you're
writing about in this book about
persuasion and what Trump is doing and
all that around that time just like two
months before his election did you
really think it was real I did really
believe that he was going to win those
weeks that we're talking about and most
of the time up to them the only time my
confidence was really shaken was at the
same time everybody else was you have to
the Access Hollywood was a gay
thing yeah dropped I don't think anybody
thought that day that he could get out
of that I haven't heard of one person
who said yeah that didn't bother me at
all but it was just amazing there was so
much news that that whole cycle and so
much more came after that that even
something that large didn't have the
impact it would have had because it got
lost and you know the the the enormity
of it all yeah what does that tell you
generally about truth right now now the
subtitle of your book is persuasion in a
world where facts don't matter facts and
truth have a little something to do with
each other what does that actually tell
you that something like that could
happen regardless of whether you think
it was just something he said or
locker-room talk or all that nonsense
but that things don't stick in a way
yeah they used to let me give some
context for people or new to me
yeah in addition to cartooning and
writing and stuff I'm a trained
hypnotist yeah and I've been studying
persuasion in all its forms for four
decades so I was looking through that
filter and one of the things that
hypnotist learned is that people are
irrational
pretty much all the time and they just
rationalize their decisions and believe
that it made sense all along and that's
the normal way of things until you get
in that mindset the whole world looks
confusing you can't understand why you
gave your good reasons and your facts
and your logic and and the person you're
talking to didn't change their mind
so my view on the election was that are
certainly by the time that the Access
Hollywood tape dropped probably almost
every mind was made up they didn't know
why but they had made up their minds for
emotionally rational whatever reasons so
it's tough to dislodge somebody you know
he would have had to murder somebody in
public to change minds at that point
that late stage because people are
really hardened in their opinions by
then yeah what does that tell you I mean
as we're taping this this will be up
next week so a little right before
Thanksgiving we're taping this on the
today's the eighth yesterday they sound
right okay that sounds you're good
you're a pro what does that tell you as
I'm watching all these people on Twitter
in the last day or so with this Thank
You Hillary hashtag and all this stuff
and this continued worship of her even
though by every estimation she probably
was the worst candidate in the history
of American politics pot that might be a
bit of an overblown statement but what
is it what does that day that they're
still on this they're still on this
thing that but Rumble but consider that
statement we consider it now a given
that she was one of the worst candidates
we've ever seen prior to the election
and really maybe up right up until
election day the general thought on both
sides was this is one of the strongest
candidates we've ever seen for
everything from funding to experience
too it was time for a for a woman people
were you know emotionally in every other
way the world was ready for that so it's
only after the fact that we've now
reinterpreted what we saw as well she
was the worst candidate ever and I don't
know if either one of those is true I
think we had two candidates who had some
real big pluses she had lots of pluses
and some real big flaws in both cases
yeah do you think that basically Trump
from before the election so during the
process until now
after a year of governing basically or
ten months or so of governing has
basically used this book I know he
didn't have it but you know what I mean
like has he is this really what he has
done from beat one that you saw before a
lot of people did so you have to
understand his entire life arc starts
with going to a church where his pastor
was norman vincent peale
the famous author who wrote the power of
positive thinking and so that's that's
the first place you probably learned
persuasion at least one corner of
persuasion because in his time norman
vincent peale was actually accused the
big a hypnotist he was that influential
so that optimism you see him using it
all the time to make us think into the
future when he talks about the GDP he
doesn't say well we got three percent
that's pretty good that's what a normal
president would say he says we've got
three percent but without the hurricanes
I think it would have been four we'll
probably got four percent I think we'll
do better than that
he's actually talking us into the future
and if you if you consider how an
economy works unless you have shortages
of stuff and we're really you know in a
great time because we don't have
shortages of anything it's psychology
that drives it so if people think we're
heading to four percent they're gonna
invest a little bit more this year to
get ready for that and that's what makes
it four percent he's actually taking
what he learned as a child and you know
that that persuasive thinking into the
future and driving the economy that way
and then if you look at his full full
range of he you know sort of cell
marketing branding nobody doubts any of
those skills at this point and then
negotiating he wrote literally you know
authored with a co-author a book on
negotiating so he's seen persuasion from
every every angle including design you
know he's the one who I believe came up
with or at least approved the the hats
and make America great again
and and I think people will look back at
this for four years and say that was the
best branding we've ever seen
yeah it's interesting to me because you
said the the positive way he speaks and
then you gave some examples but if you
listen to the just the general narrative
out there this is the most divisive
president
he says all these horrible things what
do you make of that portion of him the
the Twitter portion that's fighting with
people still all the time doing things
that in my opinion are below the office
of the presidency and I say that as
someone that that I really did the
reason I wasn't surprised when Trump won
was because I actually sat down with you
right before and I listened and I
started seeing this stuff so I wasn't
thoroughly I was on Rogan Joe Rogan the
day before the election or maybe it was
election day actually and I was like
yeah I think it's possible and did I
actually change your mind on that well I
don't know that you I don't know that
you fully changed my mind but you made
me aware of what was happening I think
basically before I sat down with you I
was sort of where I think a lot of
people still are which is they're just
grabbing for anything you know what I
mean like they're just they have nothing
that they're really basing any decisions
on they see the tweets they scream about
the tweets or they don't even have a
chance to scream about the tweets
because the media gets outraged before
they can even process it and and you
sort of framed it in a way that's
basically said to me there's something
sensible about this
yeah well I think most people have kind
of missed that one of the things that is
deeply important for a persuasion is
first you have to get people's attention
that's like you know phase one at this
point can can anybody argue that he's
the best we've ever seen at getting
attention all right let's think that one
even his biggest haters I'd say yeah
like the way he has dominated the media
and every conversation yes so step one
get attention and the way he does that
is he he operates in what I call a
narrow band of wrongness meaning that if
this is appropriate behavior he just
takes it up to this band you know with
the nicknames and the the provocative
things he says but he never goes up here
where you'd get impeached you'd be put
in the insane asylum and you start a
nuclear war if you look how long he's
been doing this and how how consistently
he stays in that narrow band of
wrongness which is persuasion perfection
because you can't look away and then
you're thinking about why he wants you
to think about now consider also that
he's also been meeting with a lot of
world leaders at this point he doesn't
do that in that context so it's clear
that he can modify his behavior to get
the effect he needs we didn't know that
for sure I'll say other people didn't
know that for sure
or you know when he was running it
looked a little crazy and maybe out of
control
but now we've seen the fine control he
puts on it you know on Twitter that
narrowband wrong this every time in real
life you can modulate everything being
equal as a smart guy and a bright guy
and an author and someone that cares
about words and all of those things
putting Trump aside for a moment would
you prefer that we just had a president
that was a little more within the common
standards of decency or seemed to really
appreciate you know I keep telling the
story that I was in DC a couple weeks
ago and I went to all the monuments I
was reading all the great things that
Jefferson wrote and George Washington
all I'm like it's very different than
when they look back and they put Trump's
tweets next to all of it well I have I
have mixed feelings for one a lot one of
the things that the people on the left
let's say the the anti-trump errs
whoever they are don't get is how
entertaining is to his base the people
who actually like what he's got to offer
find it amazingly entertaining and funny
so the things that people are saying oh
I can't believe he said that he's he's
an affront to all civilization that's
why it's funny it's funny because we
know he does it intentionally
we know the effect it'll have on a
certain group of people and that's sort
of the joke that it has that effect now
to answer your question we were never
offered somebody who had his his talents
and his specific policies that appealed
to a lot of people who voted for him
without the flaws you know nobody
offered the you know the Trump without
the tweets that make people angry and I
would argue that probably 80% of the
things that feel like they're over the
line actually are functional and the 20%
that made you know how do you mean
functional gets attention it puts a
nickname on somebody that actually takes
them completely out of the primaries we
saw that with low-energy jab and I think
the crooked Hillary thing was was quite
effective but there are other things
that are maybe just too far you know
little they don't have they're not so
far I guess impeach but they're you know
not useful but they also don't seem to
hurt him in the
we've seen something we may never see
again which is a complete disconnect
between approval ratings which are
terrible mm-hmm and people's image of
what the economy is doing for example
business confidence is great yeah I
don't think we'll ever see those
disconnect again and it's because of his
style does that also show you that
people just don't care about polls
anymore I mean I saw a poll on Sunday on
CNN and it said you know half Americans
don't trust Trump and I thought well
half Americans don't trust CNN I mean
that all of the know you know you mean
it's like you guys threw all these
numbers at us before you through all
this nonsense at us before and now
you're still throwing nonsense and I
don't try I really almost trust none of
it and I it makes it harder to siphon
some truth out and now the onus is on I
was just saying a poll that was saying
that something about what people think
the leaders think of the president and
I'm thinking how do we know what leaders
of other countries think of the
president what what good is that poll
right oh yeah we're a little why is that
even relevant in an odd way you know so
if they fear us certain countries we
want them to fear us so they probably
won't like the president whether it was
Trump or Obama or anyone else well I've
been saying from the beginning one of
the big things has scared people about a
president Trump was that how our other
leader is going to deal with this guy
you know is are they going to be
frightened will they make you know the
nucleus just in case no problem so far
it turns out that if you're the
President of the United States and you
have good table manners when you when
you talk to other leaders there's
there's nothing that they would rather
do than deal with you because it's in
their best interest and it works so I
listen to you on Sam Harris's podcast
and Sam obviously been here a bunch of
times I find him to be one of the
brightest and most thoughtful people
that I know you guys obviously differ
greatly on the on the Trump thing
probably more than anything else but
when you hear him make a couple of those
arguments
whichever one you can pick any one does
any of it get to you does any of it you
know the the moral Center just what the
what's really going on if things really
escalated with North Korea you can pick
one out of the bag well for those who
didn't hear my conversation with Sam
yeah I knew
Podcast i was not addressing the moral
ethical dimension because i figured
people are on their own for that in
other words my moral center is not much
different than everybody else's i have
exactly the same preferences if you
could do things without lying without
insulting people of course i prefer that
but nobody gave us that choice you know
we didn't get that candidate we had to
leave the choices that we had so I think
there was there's an illusion that Sam
and I disagreed on the ethical moral
stuff I simply take the position fair
yeah right because it really wasn't
addressed specifically you know was it
wasn't directly asked I don't think I
take the position that if if if a
terrorist was holding your child and the
only way I could save him is lying to
the terrorists I will lie to the
terrorists to save your child now if you
wouldn't I'm not sure that you can claim
a moral high-ground
there are some situations such as
beating Isis you know having a good
economy these are fantastically good
things for human beings if you had if
the only way you could get there is
bends bend some truths then I'm a little
bit more flexible about that but I don't
think my moral look on this is any
different than anybody else's yeah but
what about just the concerns that Sam
and others like the people that are the
real critics oh forget it forget we can
put Sam aside because I don't know if
people haven't listened to it it's not
important but when you hear people say
well Trump is so erratic and he's
dealing with an erratic leader in North
Korea and all of those things you you
basically think that that's all just
playing that that other higher bar this
way and that in reality we're still
doing well well we could talk about
North Korea separately cuz that's really
kind of it there's nothing like that
that's sort of its own situation and at
the moment I think he's handling that
right well let's talk about that yeah
what do you think about North Korea
so for however many decades we haven't
really had any progress because we they
promised things and then they don't do
them this is probably the first time
that little rocket man shall we call him
is literally worried that he'll be dead
in the next 30 days I don't think
they've ever had that thought before
and that's gotta help in the
negotiations now if you're thinking but
that might make him you know fire off a
nuke well that's the only way you could
be sure your dad so right now his only
two choices are dead for sure I don't
think he wants to make that or worrying
about being dead unless he comes to the
negotiating table and and there seems to
be some maybe a little bit of a hint of
a movement there yeah but your big
question what about all the other stuff
that that is yeah Matic yeah if you were
to list all the things that people
consider that the criticisms of Trump on
one column and then all the things that
people even as critics would say okay
these things are going well you would
find that the things that are going well
are generally real meaning that there is
less Isis stocks are up you know we they
did he did appoint justices that leased
his side likes immigration is down by
50% these are real and measurable things
and they matter and they're big if you
look at the list of things that people
are criticizing it's well we think he
might cause a problem mm-hmm
we think this could go wrong we're
concerned that people think about him
this way we think that his supporters
are you know more racist than they are
almost all of them would would be
legitimately classified as imaginary now
that's not to say that there couldn't be
bad things in the future but at the
moment they are purely imagined yeah
it's interesting because I was on Sam's
AMA podcast and we discussed this and I
mentioned or he brought up the interview
with you but that's what I said too
basically I said look I didn't even vote
for the guy I brought on many for the
week before the election I had Hillary
Rosen who's a progressive operative
basically to come on and talk about why
not to vote for him but then I had
people like you and others on and tried
to talk to everybody about it but ice
basically said that two sandwiches the
things that he's actually been able to
do are basically mainstream Republican
things that if any other Republican
would have done the things that he
hasn't been able to do actually show the
strength of our system because if you
don't like the his health care plan or
the tax plan or whatever US Congress is
fighting him and that's the way the
government supposed to work and the
other things the tweets and
all the other stuff it's like well
that's just not that's just nothing it's
just stuff you know take healthcare so
so if you were gonna make a criticism
about the President's performance
Healthcare would be at the top of the
list of criticisms and this is this
illustrates what I call the the two
movies on one screen we're all looking
at the same set of facts and and we're
producing completely different movies in
our minds about what's happening so some
people will say well he hasn't solved
healthcare that's that's a failure but
my observation is what was the deadline
for that but is there a time you're
supposed to be done and that that it
that passed because I don't see the
deadline what I see is somebody who let
the Republicans go first fail hard
because they were going to they didn't
have a plan that was going to be popular
scare the left while letting the the
right fail as hard as they can and then
what's he do he says well maybe I'll
talk to the Democrats until he gets both
of them in this situation setting the
table he calls it he actually has a word
for this right this is not accidental
you know if your brand is negotiating
and you do things that any objective
person who understands negotiating
recognizes as correct technique he's
softening up both sides and it's going
to take a while it might take Obama care
to fail a little harder it might take
the public to see their either their
costs going up in Obamacare that's not a
good thing but it might be the only way
you can get these two sides that are on
such opposites somewhere in the middle
yeah so as he failed I would say it's a
process and it's probably the only way
it could go how much are you concerned
at all that the people around him this
is one of the things I hear a lot that
the people around him bet for either
certain things aren't staffed right now
I in her I don't have that much of a
problem with that because I think the
government should be a lot smaller as a
general rule but putting that aside that
people say the well the intellectual
acumen around him isn't that great like
you've got these players around him
these people that understand a lot of
things you're talking about but not sort
of like a serious group of like
intellects around him well in what
department you know does he really need
help in the State Department because the
the international stuff looks like it's
going pretty well
does he need help in the
MECs seems like it's going really well
does he need more help than general
mattis to beat Isis mattis is doing
great now if you get down to you know
the Department of Agriculture and you
know the EPA and stuff
those are real arguments you can have
about whether you've got the right
horsepower there and and I would I would
listen to those arguments for sure but
in terms of how much is staffed and
whether there's enough staff I'm still
waiting for that to matter well it sort
of goes to that other point of just two
other things there's some literal things
that have happened and some maybes and
creditors do you ever feel like you're
stuck sort of acting as his counsel
publicly or something yeah I suddenly
felt like I was like really grilling you
on Trump and it was in an odd way
because we're obviously going to talk
about your book too but it's all
intertwined yeah it's funny in my mind
it's always about persuasion and about a
more effective way to see the world that
does a better job but predicting you
know I guess it's now a year and a half
ago I said that he would do more than
change politics and boy has he changed
politics but I said he would rip a hole
in our reality to let us look through
and see something completely different
and he's done that because didn't you
used to think that facts mattered and
didn't usually think that if somebody
said as many things as he said that the
fact checker said oh no that doesn't
that doesn't work that you couldn't
possibly become president and if you did
you couldn't possibly have a good
economy beat Isis and all the other
things he's doing none of it was true
and if you were a trained persuader you
could see that early you could see that
none of that would matter because you
can see that his his persuasive skill
was that strong now I have to jump in to
just say one point yeah
facts do matter to outcomes and all
things being equal we would love to get
the accurate facts but usually when he's
non-factual he's persuading in the
direction that we would like so if he
says the number of deaths by a gun in
Chicago or a thousand per day but it's
really 10 per day we still need to fix
that problem and he made us focus on it
the fact that it wasn't accurate did it
matter it
and now and I think he knows it and I
think it's conscious and he calls it a
hyperbole he has a name for it yeah yeah
well that was gonna be my follow-up
question do you think he's really
conscious of all of this stuff I would
feel I guess I would feel better if I
really thought he was conscious of all
if I knew he was conscious of all I
guess I would feel better
he's kind yet it's the same time that
would mean he intentionally these are
lies I mean if he knows them and he's
and he's intentionally doing it even if
it's for all the reasons that you lay
out here in the book that's still it
then it then it's an outright lie as
opposed to just an exaggeration or
hyperbole well I would say that you have
to consider intention at this point I
don't see any scenario in which the good
of the country and how he does
personally are separated right you know
he has to do a good job for the country
so if he's telling a lie that's good for
him and bad for the country that's just
a frickin lie right nobody's in favor of
that but if he says hey you know we've
got a you know fight extra hard to fix
this problem that everybody wants fixed
and there's a little bit of an
exaggeration in that well it's still the
direction we do want to go it's that
it's so you know those situations you
can call it a lie you could call it
someone who didn't pass the
fact-checking he would call it hyperbole
because he's he's a it's a sort of an
exaggerated truth if you will in other
words directionally it's true just the
details are wrong so as a guy that wrote
one of the most popular has written one
of those popular comic strips of all
time the whole purpose I mean I think of
comic strips and of stand-up every does
is that you're getting to a kernel of
truth at the end of that day right like
every time you I assume is that is that
fair to say that every time you ever
wrote a strip that there's a kernel of
truth at the end right if you do it
right yes if you do it right so how can
you also be the guy that's saying that
it's okay to live in a fax no matter
place like facts and truth there's
that's I wrote there right I love that
you asked that question because this is
just a perfect way to make the point the
comic strip is an exaggerated world it's
a it's just a crazy you know something
that wouldn't actually happen in the
real
world but what people say about it is
that is just like my job hmm so they're
looking at something that's this crazy
world and they're still seeing the truth
and so if you're a good cartoonist you
you've made both of those things happen
that shouldn't be together you know and
so that's a perfect example that I get
to see every day where people say that's
just like my office and I say no there
were no aliens in your office you know
if somebody's had exploded that didn't
happen in your office you know so stuff
in the comics people we regard as
feeling real when they clearly or not
that's interesting are you familiar with
the term K fab the it's the term that
wrestlers use that you know that's the
fakery that you know everyone knows it's
fake we all know it's fake we're and yet
you're you're eliciting real emotions
from people that go there and pay you to
do something fake and have a real
emotion and I think there is some
connection with that and and what you're
talking about in the Trump was kind of
you know he was a fan of wrestling he's
there's those clips of him I think at
WrestleMania and taken out Vince McMahon
and the rest of it he is playing that
game he has merged theater and politics
like nobody has ever done and that he
just happens to be good at the theater
stuff and so he effectively merged them
I don't think we'll ever see this again
the this is a very special situation and
he has I've probably said this before
but he has a talent stack of individual
talents that he's a b-plus a-minus act
but there's so many of them and they
work so well together all of his
persuasion stuff is his theater stuff is
public speaking his you know his
intelligence they're all they're all
high but you'd say to yourself wow we've
had smarter presidents we've had better
orators orators orators yeah people who
speak better than I do even right one
way or another Natalie on those yeah but
very few people have had that
combination with business experience
with with his ability to take criticism
even though people say he's thin-skinned
you don't get into this game unless you
you know you can handle the criticism
[Music]
you